There is a quicker way to think about our process though. When simplifying
radicals that involve variables, we want to remember power divided by root. For
example, if we wanted to simplify the square root of x to the fourth, we would
do the power of the 4 divided by the root 2, so we would get x squared. We're
dividing this power by our index of 2, since it's the square root. This should
also make sense because x to the 4th can be rewritten as x squared times x
squared. We have a repeated factor here so we can pull out x squared. We can
use this same approach of power divided by root for higher order roots like
cube roots, fourth roots and fifth roots. So how do you think we could simplify
this radical? Write your answer here.